[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-♪ I've got a sad girl at home ♪
♪ She wants to hang up
the phone ♪
♪ It's been a long year,
the wrong year ♪
♪ To be left alone ♪
♪ Promises made,
sandcastles break ♪
♪ Wave after wave ♪
♪ Promises made,
go ahead, change ♪
♪ I see you the same ♪
♪ I don't wanna wait to get
where we're going ♪
♪ Scared to death of dying,
not really knowing you, you ♪
♪ Every shade of blue ♪
♪ Underneath the sky,
out in the open ♪
♪ Every little bit,
can't get enough of you, you ♪
♪ Every shade,
every shade of blue ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
♪ She's made of water and wine ♪
♪ It's only natural she cries ♪
♪ You can't imagine
that it's magic ♪
♪ Any time she smiles ♪
♪ Promises made,
sandcastles break ♪
♪ Wave after wave ♪
♪ Promises made,
go ahead, change ♪
♪ I see you the same ♪
♪ I don't wanna wait to get
where we're going ♪
♪ Scared to death of dying,
not really knowing you, you ♪
♪ Every shade of blue ♪
♪ Underneath the sky,
out in the open ♪
♪ Every little bit,
can't get enough of you, you ♪
♪ Every shade,
every shade of blue ♪
♪ What if tonight
was never ending ♪
♪ Make a fortress in the dark ♪
♪ Somewhere that we can stop
pretending ♪
♪ And just be happy
where we are ♪
♪♪
♪ I'll be happy where we are ♪
♪ I don't wanna wait to get
where we're going ♪
♪ Scared to death of dying,
not really knowing you, you ♪
♪ Every shade of blue ♪
♪ Underneath the sky,
out in the open ♪
♪ Every little bit,
can't get enough of you, you ♪
♪ Every shade,
every shade of blue ♪
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Thank you so much.